a top trending article in usa today
makes a bold claim
claim is conservatives want to ban
transgender athletes from girls sports
now that obviously
is not the controversial part the
controversial part is the next sentence
their evidence is shaky
our evidence of course is that they're
not girls
that that's our that's our whole
evidence but these guys here
don't understand what evidence or
science or arguments
are which may be why president biden's
energy department is turning
its scientific grants into a racial
grievance contest
might be why scientific conferences now
charge different prices based on race
might be why joe biden himself blames
the sun monster
for a tragic building collapse in
florida i'm expert scientist michael
knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from aslan
mitchell says if daily wire ever needs
to rename its shows i propose the
following
facts with ben shapiro the apocalypse
with andrew clavin
the bad news with matt walsh and i told
you so with michael knowles oh you're so
right
actually you're so right because you
realize that i was so right and we're
going to get into that
today first though when things are
getting a little crazy i would strongly
recommend you
hedge your investments with acre gold
everybody's worried about inflation
right now
as well they should be well one great
way to hedge against inflation
physical gold but michael you say i
don't have enough money in the couch
cushions to invest in physical gold what
if i told you that you do
what do you have thirty dollars well you
can start investing in physical gold
because acre has figured out this
ingenious way to start investing in
physical precious metals
without coming out of pocket all at once
they've got their 30
a month subscription where you pay your
30
a month when your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars they will
discreetly ship
acre gold to your door they also have a
100 a month subscription
to a five gram gold bar they keep you
updated every month on where your gold
stash is and then they'll send it to you
it's really
great stuff to have i've really enjoyed
investing in precious metals
i really enjoy investing in acre gold
check out
getacregold.com knowles today start
investing in physical gold
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getacre gold.com
knowles and thank you aker gold for
supporting the show conservatives want
to ban transgender athletes from girls
sports their evidence is shaky what do
you think our
evidence is now what they mean i want to
be charitable i don't want to just straw
me in this article it's very thick
article i can't believe they wrote this
much about this
obvious topic their evidence they say is
that
you know some of the men who when we say
transgender people by the way we mean
men who are pretending to be women some
of the men you know actually
don't necessarily have this perfect
advantage because of this
level of hormones i mean for just as a
practical matter they almost always win
the sports but
you know but actually the testosterone
level is this and
because of that this that's not our
evidence that's not our evidence
the reason that men should not compete
in girls sports
is not because they have an extra
bit of testosterone or their shoulders
are broader their hips are narrower
they're taller they're fast
the reason the most basic reason
is that they're not girls and girls
sports by definition are for
girls so if you're not a girl you
shouldn't compete
you don't need to take any measurements
you don't need to draw any blood you
don't need to do any
difficult calculations to understand
that bit of evidence and that argument
but what the left does because it is now
so scientistic
is it it doesn't understand
what a what an argument is it doesn't
understand what philosophy is
doesn't understand what arguments from
human nature are
all it understands is this very sort of
rigorous
materialist physical process that then
they kind of totally pervert in this way
i mean
just from a scientific perspective husky
hank is going to run
faster than sweet little helen okay it's
just that's just a fact i don't need
advanced degrees to know that only a
scientist only an intellectual
could possibly think that that's a
confusing or complicated question
but science because it has been made
into this idol by the left
it has to fulfill all the roles of
philosophy of religion
of the longings of the human heart and
so it gets perverted all the time
the department of energy right now under
joe biden
department of energy makes certain
grants right so this is from the office
of
energy efficiency and renewable energy
either they're making
different funding grants they are
encouraging uh racial minorities women
and
veteran veterans to become the prime
applicants or a proposed partner to the
prime applicant what that means is
the selection official may consider the
inclusion of these types of entities as
part of this election all of that is
bureaucratic gobbledygook to say that
this ostensibly scientific endeavor
is going to prioritize black people and
hispanics
and maybe asians but probably not
and it's going to disadvantage white
people but i thought this was a
scientific process i thought we were
just only after the truth
i thought only the best scientists would
win why are we now
saying that it's more important that you
have
let's say you've got all things being
equal
a white scientist and a black scientist
it's going to have to go to the black
scientist
even further let's say all things being
equal you've got a or let's say
all things not being equal you've got a
black scientist who is performing at a
lower
rate and you've got a white scientist
performing at a higher rate you'll still
in some cases give the grant to the
black scientists because of
this racial ideology what's what's the
evidence there
what it what it's not it's you're making
a moral argument
that it's better to reward black people
than white people even if the black
people are not performing as well
like that okay that's a moral you can
try to make that argument fair enough
but it's not there's nothing scientific
about it we're just using that word
science to mean everything
in the same way that now we refer to
white supremacy as just a synonym for
sin you know every bad thing that's ever
happened is because of white supremacy
now because we just don't understand how
to think about
philosophy or religion or morality it's
the same thing here
now in science everything
good and true and beautiful in the world
is just science because it's a
substitute for god because the left
makes an idol out of it
but this is not particularly scientific
there's a marine science conference
right now
called the p p o c c s e
a 2021 conference it's a virtual
conference
for the marine science bi-poc community
bipoc is the new term for
black people and they include indigenous
in there too which means indians
feather not dot so they're going to
let the buy pock in for free and they're
going to charge white scientists 10
to show up as an ally so obviously the
point here is not
scientific inquiry the point here is not
to discover truth the point is
to create a racial caste system to treat
white people as a sort of second-class
citizen certainly in the scientific
endeavor
and to treat bipoc but
whatever that is you know to treat bipoc
as
as a first-class citizen within
the scientific endeavor not science it's
a new political order it's a new caste
system it's deeply ideological but it's
not
science what about this this terrible
building collapse in florida what caused
the building collapse well
obviously people ignoring some warning
signs not doing some work on the
building itself not doing upkeep and
maintenance
or says president biden not even just
one of his
lackeys but president biden himself it
was probably caused by
climate change we don't have any
firm proof of what's happened there's
all kinds of
rational speculation about whether or
not
the rebars are where were rusted and
interesting to me
i didn't raise it but how many
of the survivors and how many of the
families talked about
the impact of global warming how much it
and
did they know exactly but they talked
about sea levels rising and about
how how they were and and the
combination of that and the concern
about incoming
storms incoming tropical storms
global warming which is also by the way
an unscientific theory unscientific in
the sense that it can't be disproven
it it the temperature goes up it's
global warming temperature goes down
well now they call it climate change
temperature goes up it's climate change
temperature goes down it's climate
change temperature stays the same it's
climate change
you can't deny it it's the same argument
from ibram kendy and those guys
on the race hustling left they'll say if
you admit that you're a racist you're a
racist if you deny that you're a racist
you're definitely a racist so you're
just a racist
it's called begging the question it's
called assuming your own conclusion
which is a philosophical error and a
scientific one as well you can't
you can't begin and end in the same
place
because you began in that place not that
is not how the
inquiry works this is why i think
people do not trust the scientists
because the scientists
do not really understand what science is
they don't the people
scientists and the people who are
popularizing science they don't
understand even what arguments we're
making whether it's on transgender
sports
or infrastructure which is what's going
on in this building collapse
or the pursuit of science itself this is
why by the way a lot of people
are hesitant to get the vaccine you know
there i really don't want to get the
stupid thing i'm probably going to
because my best friend is having a
wedding overseas so i'm going
i probably have to do it you know and i
because i love my friend i'm willing to
do it
but i otherwise i would be hesitant to
do it because i'm not at ri i'm a young
person
and i'm i'm noticing i'm not at risk
right i'm at very very low risk from it
so i'm making a prudential judgment
and i know that the scientists have been
lying to me from the beginning and the
people who are reporting on the science
have been mis either lying out right or
misunderstanding what
the science is we've made an idol out of
this thing
and and we're using it to justify all
sorts of ideological nonsense whether
it's redefining the sexes whether it's
creating a racial caste system
or whether it's upending the political
order in the economy on climate change
because we're blaming every tragedy in
the world on that
absolutely crazy stuff makes you just
want to tune out when you want to tune
in i would recommend checking out
the jordan harbinger show i know every
day somebody tells you that you just
have to listen to some new podcast and
you say oh yeah sure maybe and then you
don't listen to it
don't let that happen here you've got to
check out the jordan harbinger show
recently jordan had oliver north on his
show you know ollie north
the woke mob really came after him for
this he said that he's been getting
attacked just for doing the interview
each episode has a conversation with a
different fascinating guest in one
episode jordan talks to a hostage
negotiator
from the fbi who offers techniques on
how to get people to like and trust you
which sounds pretty useful and
disturbing at the same time but they but
they know how to do it and you can hear
about it too
lots of science some pretty crazy
stories from spies
mafia enforcers art foragers this guy
he's really got everything a really
really broad podcast
really like this show we think you will
as well there's just so much there go
check out jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or you can search for the jordan
harbinger show
h-a-r-b as in boy i n as in nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcasts a
topic
that i keep coming back to when i think
about how we're so misunderstanding
america we're so misunderstanding
science we're so misunderstanding we
just don't we don't even know what we
don't know yesterday on the show
we talked about don rumsfeld the known
knowns the known unknowns and the
unknown unknowns and even
the known unknowns no the unknown knowns
it's very very confusing you understand
but we can't we can't even make sense of
those things because our standards have
fallen
and we no one possesses really a liberal
education anymore
and you know a proper education to know
about our culture to make sense of our
own freedom
and to liberate ourselves from our bases
passions and our ignorance
one guy wants to change that glenn
yunken
he is a candidate for governor of
virginia
he is outlining a plan to quote restore
an academic standard of excellence in
virginia schools
and return common sense to the classroom
i'm going to pause it there this is
really good stuff
too often you hear conservatives
prattling on about the free marketplace
of ideas in a fifth grade classroom or
how we shouldn't you know we
we shouldn't indoctrinate we need to
educate and we need to and we need to
expand the curriculum and include
everything no bogus not true
you can't expand a curriculum it's not
possible there are only so many weeks in
a semester there are
only so many books you can read some
things are true some things are false we
should not include false things some
things are good some things are bad we
should not include
bad things we should as governor
desantis is doing now in florida
teach on the evils of communism i'm not
saying don't teach marx who don't teach
communism i just wrote a whole book
outlining a lot of what marx and his
ideological layers had to say
but it's bad we must have a perspective
on these things
that is that is the way education works
so i love that glenn young is using this
word standards
it's not just total free academic
freedom whatever you want for pursue
whatever you wanted no
there are standards now there's a big
movement on the left
get rid of standardized tests why
because
we want to increase the number of people
of color
by poc i guess in the universities and
if they're doing poorly relatively
poorly on standardized tests
that must mean there's a problem with
the standardized test so you got to get
rid of it
right that's that's what's going on so
what
what the virginia governor canada is
saying is we need a standard of
excellence
now here's the this is the one problem i
have with the statement he says we need
to restore an academic standard of
excellence in virginia schools and
return common sense to the classroom
here's a problem so that children are
taught how to think
instead of what to think
no no i'm afraid not it's go i don't
want to knock this guy too much because
i think he's doing really good stuff and
i think he's a good candidate but that
is a meaningless expression
you cannot know how to think if you do
not
in some sense know what to think you
can't know how to think about advanced
mathematics
if you don't know that two plus two
equals four you can't know how to think
about american history
if you don't know that the revolution
begins in 1776
you need to know certain hard facts and
you need to be told
that they are true and if you think that
they're false you need to be punished
with a bad grade okay
you you have to it's this problem we
want to educate not indoctrinate no the
words mean the same thing okay it's just
one is good and one is bad
they have those connotations but we
actually we need to go further good i'm
glad
we've moved from the the insane sort of
liberal canard of free marketplace of
ideas
academic freedom which the left has
never in practice really believed in
it's just a trick to fool conservatives
into abandoning our standards we've
moved from that into we need academic
standards of excellence cool awesome
love that
now we knew newton now we knew we need
to move
further into we will tell
in some ways students what to think
you have to it is that is just what
education is
i'm not saying it's got to be adject
prop and brainwashing i'm not suggesting
that at all
but you need to establish a kind of
baseline
because when when you present facts to
students
those facts imply certain things about
the good and the true
and the beautiful okay speaking of which
since this is
the thesis of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds no
more bells were rid of the bells
i just want to thank all of the readers
you readers
made speechless the number one
best-selling nonfiction book in the
entire country last week i'm really
floored i'm really pleased thank you so
much i i thought the book would sell
well because i've been shielding it
relentlessly
for about six months as you well know
ding ding ding but i
i really did not expect it to hit number
one it is number one on the publisher
weekly
chart making it a number one national
bestseller the publisher weekly chart
is is the one tied to book sales and uh
there were no sometimes people will buy
books in bulk or any that's that's not
what we did we did not do any bulk sales
it was all you guys flooding tim poole's
super chats
and ordering ordering your copy so thank
you so much uh we conspicuously even
though we we
are the top selling book in the country
right now in nonfiction
conspicuously we're missing from the new
york times list
so shocking isn't it almost as though
that's um
part of the thesis of my book uh so we
but i do want to thank you because we've
sold
according to bookscan which is the
industry standard according to
publishers weekly
we sold about 18 000 copies just just a
little under that
in a week that's way ahead of the second
and third place books
uh which were by bill o'reilly and
malcolm gladwell they sold
13 000 and 9 000 roughly respectively so
about 5 000 more than number two
even though that number two is number
one on the new york times list and we
sold
many multiples more than some of the uh
the lower books on the new york times
list so i'm just i'm just really pleased
with that thank you so much
keep telling your friends uh because i'm
i'm hoping
that that through the book we can change
the conversation on a lot i think
i think the right is doing a good job
we're starting to give up some of those
losing strategies
we're starting to give up some of the
canards and the lies that the left
tricked us into believing
but i want to take it a little bit
further uh as we head into 2022
2024 and hopefully time is running out a
little bit here
hopefully we can grab a little political
power back which reminds me
of the squishes i have you know my book
is
is really not so much geared at the
evils of the left as it is at the just
cowardice of the squishes it's just the
squishes are driving me nuts
and liz cheney did it again she did it
again you know liz cheney who was
formerly one of the republican leaders
she was uh
chairman of the house gop conference
then
she just relentlessly attacked the right
relentlessly attacked trump they took a
vote they held her in for a while then
finally they couldn't defend her anymore
it's like she's auditioning for her cnn
contributorship and so she
so they voted her out and now she
uh she is accepting a spot
on nancy pelosi's select committee
to investigate january 6th
the gravest most horrific attack in
in frankly in our nation's history
forget
september 11th forget the world trade
center or forget to
pearl harbor rather forget the war of
1812 the guy in the horn helmet dancing
on nancy pelosi's desk right
by the way i'm not i'm not just making
this up this is what they're saying
they're
they are actually it's so offensive that
they're comparing
the guy in the horn hat or the other guy
taking pelosi's lectern
to september 11th or pearl harbor
absolutely insane that's why by the way
that's why they're calling it january
6th is to make it seem like september
11th even though the two events
completely incomparable and liz cheney
is taking a spot here so kevin mccarthy
was the house minority leader
he he issued a threat and he said that
he would strip
any republican member of their committee
assignments if they accept an offer
from house speaker nancy pelosi to serve
on this committee so you've got
a couple people you've got cheney and
you've got kinzinger who's this other
total squish
who said well that's why i don't care we
need to serve on the committee that's
not who we are
whatever you know whatever nonsense they
say and so so they're going to do that
this
this is worse than democrats it is worse
people point out i have pointed out that
liz cheney has quite a conservative
voting record
it it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if
when the tough political issues come up
the actual
fights for practical power not your view
on an issue
in the abstract not your own ideological
musings in your dorm room but
actually when it comes down to practical
who's got the political power here
if you're now always siding with the
democrats
that makes you worse than a democrat
because
you're you're a you're a traitor to your
party and to your constituents
so it's a really really big problem we
got to
we got to get these guys out of the
party i don't know i wish
it's too bad liz cheney's got a lot of
good views on a lot of good things
but when it comes to the practice of
power she's just always wrong and
undermining the gop these days some
people say we you know trump was
terrible for the republican party
we need to get back to the true
conservatives like um
adam kinzinger who is that what i've
only
only ever heard that guy's name in the
context of criticizing republicans and
conservatives this reminds me that trump
for all his flaws has been much
much better for the republican party
than
liz cheney adam kinzinger
you know the net the future msnbc
contributor
or any of these other jokers and
actually some polls bear this up
we now know according to pew research
president trump
boosted his support among hispanics in
the 2020 election
and fairly significantly by the way
so trump won just three in 10
college-educated hispanics that's too
bad but he won 41 percent of
non-college-educated hispanics
uh now that's compared to joe biden's 55
that's no good
uh he uh unfortunately with trump though
he took a hit
among non-college educated whites
so they they only backed him uh 66
in 2020 that's compared to 73 in 2016
and then especially when you get to
non-college educated white
men that's that's the real problem
because it's not even just non-college
educated white's generally it's the
non-college-educated white men that was
a real base and trump
kind of moved away from that base and he
he embraced certain things
that were a little more liberal or
seemed a little bit more pandering i'm
thinking of the first step
act i'm thinking of
a number of policies that did not
it's go you want to make gains among all
sorts of groups
and you know trump did a pretty good job
among minority voters compared to
previous republicans
but you can't do that at the expense of
losing your base
you know that that sort of is the trump
base and that
i think of you know trump famously said
we love the undereducated
we love the uneducated people made fun
of him for it this is very important
the parents showing up to the school
board meetings right now demanding that
crt and transgenderism get out of the
schools
they may be less educated they may have
fewer degrees than the people
running the educational institutions but
they're much smarter
they're much much smarter i i want my
country to be run by those people
not by the people running the various
educational institutions okay
you got to figure out where the threats
are coming from one great way to do that
with ring
you want to protect your home you need
to protect your home you want to make it
easy to protect your home well i've got
a simple answer four letters
one syllable ring ring will let you
protect your home whether you
are in your home at the office on the
other side of the world you can see and
speak to whoever is at your doorstep
so if it's the delivery guy oh hey
delivery guy leave the package just
right there
if it's the pizza oh hey pizza guy yeah
i'll be right there if it's your
mother-in-law
silence i find is no i'm i'm joking am i
joking
head on over check out ring today the
ring alarm is so easy to install
even i can do it you'll protect every
inch of your
house makes me feel really good when i'm
on the road to know that sweet little
alisa
and cute little june are safe and sound
so make sure you do that makes a great
housewarming gift because it's super
cool super high tech and
not very expensive so you get off the
hook with a relatively inexpensive gift
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com knowles get
your ring alarm security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes
ring.com knowles that is ring.com
knowles there is a really rough crime
story out right now
i don't focus on individual crime
stories too often but this one was
pretty
pretty sick stuff joel arseniega
sainz a 25 year old illegal alien
was indicted by a grand jury this week
because he was arrested for
murdering 51 year old james garcia in
new mexico the day after father's day
he decapitated garcia then mutilated the
rest of his body
and then started kicking his head around
like a soccer ball
the reason i bring it up is not just the
gruesome details it's because at the
time of the murder
arcinega sans was out on bail he had
previously been arrested
and they just let him out on bail
because you see we need criminal justice
we need the first step back we need a
second step act we need to let the
we need to let these people out of
prison we need to abolish prisons darn
it
that's what i've been told prisons are
the modern day slavery
is what i've been told but then the
problem is when you let out the
prisoners right when you let out the
criminals they um decapitate people and
kick their heads around like soccer
balls do you think that's good do you
think it's for justice
do you think that's increasing equality
and flourishing and
liberty in the country i don't think it
is i don't think it is at all
i noticed this yesterday bill cosby got
out on a technicality you saw that
and everyone was complaining about this
fair enough but i thought we were
supposed to abolish prisons
i thought we were i thought there were
too many black men in prison remember
that's what we were
explicitly in a racial appeal prisons
are the new jim crow or something
black man got out of prison isn't that
good well no it's bad why is it because
it's bill cosby
but if we abolish prisons we have
nowhere to put bill cosby
even if we got to keep him in jail the
theory
of this that what we're being told in
theory and sold in theory
seems a little bit different when you
read the stories of guys kicking
people's heads around or rapists going
free or whatever
whatever you want to read crime of all
sorts going up including attacks on cops
tax on cops are going up 91
according to the national fraternal
order of police
91 since 2020. that's not playing very
well in peoria so jen saki
on behalf of biden and the white house
and the democrats
is really denying that she's gaslighting
everyone she's she's said this before
she said
republicans are the ones who want to
defund the police because they didn't
vote for some spending bill right so
it's
such a preposterous thinking democrats
come out and say we need to abolish the
police it means getting rid of the
police departments we at least need to
defund them they start actually doing
that in various cities
then that hurts their poll numbers so
now
saki blames republicans for this on the
flimsy excuse that they didn't vote for
some random spending bill from the
federal government
so peter ducey at fox news really good
reporter
starts pushing her on this he says well
can you name the republicans
who have voted to defund the police who
have supported that
saki comes up short mentioned at the
last briefing that you think republicans
wanted to defund the police because they
did not support the american rescue plan
which republican ever said that they did
not like the american rescue plan
because they wanted to defund the police
well first let me just note that
the president ran and won the most votes
of any candidate in history on a
platform of boosting funding for law
enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program there's record
of that
that doesn't require anyone having new
comments
and then also stood in the way of
crucial funding needed to prevent the
laying off of police officers as crimes
increased that's a simple statement of
fact that's a simple statement of fact
that's the
because they didn't come on come on jen
you could do better than that peter
ducey hits the nail on that he says okay
if you're going to try to make this
silly argument
just name me one republican who wants to
defund the police because i could name
you a bunch of democrats like aoc
ilhan omar you know this that and the
other thing the whole squad i guess
and then and more as well certainly when
you get
to the state and local level name me one
republican
they can't so they obfuscate and they
try to make false equivalences
false equivalence is a is really a big
issue right now and i
i hope that if we take if people take
nothing from
my book speechless i hope they take this
idea that
false equivalence is a tool of the left
the supposedly neutral liberal ground
is a secular ground it's a tool of the
left
you you actually can know things i was
reminded of this when lil nass
x who is that satanist homosexual rap
singer
the one who who did the whole video
twerking on
on satan's face and because he came out
of the closet
as not not only he came out of the
closet as gay he also came out of the
closet as a satanist
selling shoes with human blood in them
you know that
that's not good that's that's not good
at all he he showed up to an award show
wearing a big dress that compared the
catholic church
to the nazis he showed up to the 2021
bet awards on sunday
uh with a dress that said de usland
which was a reference to deutschland but
it was deus land and had kind of nazi
imagery on it
some somebody brought up school prayer
on the show the other day and i said
or they brought it up actually on
twitter and i said i'm i'm in favor of
school prayer and someone said well yeah
well should we have a
what if i want to have a prayer to satan
would you support that and i said no i
would not support that but i would
support a prayer to god
and they said to me well how can you
support a prayer to god
at school in the morning like we had in
this country for most of its history
until the 1960s
how can you support a prayer to god in
schools but
but then say we can't have a prayer to
satan and
my answer is because god and satan are
different
they're they're very different things
well what what if
my god is satan well then you're in
trouble buster
you better stop that that's not good but
what
but but come on you know it's like
they're both
um uh supernatural
beings okay yeah sure but they're
different
just like natural beings can be
different this microphone is different
than this leftist ears tumbler
we can make distinctions and i i'm not
just talking here about
little nas acts or the school prayer
you see this really with david french's
argument on drag queen story hour he
says that if if we
can't tell perverts that they can't
twerk for kids in the library then
then they might tell us that we can't go
to church on sunday which frankly
they're already doing
and they've been doing it for a year and
a half and and
which by the way if we
if we cannot state that drag queen story
hour
is different and worse than going to
church on sunday
we can't govern ourselves
self-government requires that we have
faculties of reason and moral conscience
if we don't have that if we actually
can't tell the difference
between drag queen story hour and church
on sunday if we can't tell the
difference
between god and satan then we can't tell
the difference between good and bad and
right and wrong and true and false and
so we've got to give up self-government
which increasingly we're doing to the
fouchus of the world
and that's too bad that's really really
too bad i like self-government
i like our constitutional system i want
to keep it okay
there's a lot of men fought for this
country if america needs anything right
now it's heroes and the daily wires
started a new podcast
to provide exactly that it's called
america's forgotten heroes it boasts
seven action-packed episodes
illuminating men whose heroic acts have
not received the recognition they
deserve
this episode focuses on the pioneer of
blind flying
and recipient of the medal of honor
jimmy doolittle who thundered into the
tokyo skies
seemingly out of nowhere to lead an
airborne raid designed to avenge the
attack on pearl harbor
standing at only five foot six jimmy
doolittle smarts and courage
towered over most and he revolutionized
piloting as we
once knew it his name may be
overshadowed by the raid he led
but it is worth remembering he wasn't
just a pilot he was a man who changed
the world subscribe now to america's
forgotten heroes on apple podcast
spotify
or anywhere you might listen because the
second episode is out today friday july
2nd
and one new action-packed episode drops
each day through the fourth of july
weekend and into next week for a total
of seven episodes thank you for
listening
and thank you to the heroes that made
such a superb podcast possible we'll be
right back with the mailbag all right
first question from kay
hey michael can you describe what
terrible beliefs gnome chomsky holds and
why he's a scumbag pink oh comey trash
lefty
thank you i think you've done a fair
enough job at that gay
you know the only noam chomsky is a very
famous leftist intellectual and you can
still watch a lot of his
debates so much of it has to do with the
vietnam war that's where he
really started to find his political
voice you can see debates between him
and buckley for instance
and others as well uh yeah i think
you're right he holds a lot of
commie trash lefty pinko views but it's
worth pointing out with chomsky
chomsky is a linguist that's his area of
expertise and he has very interesting
things to say
about linguistics and i'm very
interested in the things he has to say
about linguistics
he's probably best known as a public
intellectual for talking about
politics for talking about american
imperialism for talking about
aspects of even of our domestic society
and he's very bad when he's talking
about those things it is a reminder
that just because someone has brilliant
insight into one field
does not mean that they will have
brilliant insight into all fields
and so i actually i don't beat up on
chomsky too much because he he is
genuinely
and a very intelligent man who has some
very interesting things to say about
some things
but he's got really dumb things to say
about other things and so we gotta we
gotta make sure that we use our
our prudence and our judgment to to know
where we should
listen to them and where we probably
shouldn't from joe dear michael a
swarthiest one
after watching your show from last week
about not fighting with pigs because we
would both get dirty and they would like
it
i decided to stop engaging a leftist
friend of mine from our days at our
catholic high school
the discussions turned into one-sided
attacks which ended in her referring to
me as leftists often do
racist homophobe blah blah blah if we
are not to engage in debate with these
people
because they never have good intentions
what should we do to possibly help these
misguided souls a fellow sinner
well it depends what kind of debate
we're talking about
if you're talking about the kind of
debate that would persuade somebody
that can take different forms i mean i
always answer people's questions i don't
i don't go proselytizing all the time
but i but i always do answer people's
questions
even if they're not going to like the
answer and i do so in a way that i i try
to employ
various rhetorical devices to be more
persuasive to them there's nothing wrong
with that you don't need to be
flamboyant about everything and have the
maga hat on and start clubbing your your
your friends and
ideological debate partners over the
head
all the time you can try to seduce them
with with a little bit of honey you know
the honey catches more bees than vinegar
does
you don't want to be dishonest but you
but you do want to use various
rhetorical devices
however if the purpose of the debate is
let's say it's before an audience
and the debate is really just a clobber
the other guy well then that's going to
involve you using different tools
you've got to be wise as a serpent
innocent
as a dove not the other way around from
cammy
hey michael love the show love hearing
your mailbag advice that being said here
we go here's the butt
i have a question i'm a woman in my
mid-20s and in today's dating world
i am constantly being told by other
girls if he wanted to he would
meaning that if a guy is interested in
you he will go out of his way to hang
out with and make it
known no matter what my brothers have
told me they hate that phrase because it
is not an absolute and guys can have
insecurities and overthink things too
this isn't to say that a guy shouldn't
pursue you but sometimes it might be
more than
if he wanted to i would love to hear
your opinion on this sincerely
a woman needs a man like jelly needs
peanut butter not needed but much better
together
your brothers are right actually i think
my mailbag is good evidence of this
how many times do i get letters in from
young men who say
michael how do i talk to a girl there's
a girl that i like but i don't know how
to talk to her there's a girl
how do i go up to her what do i say what
do i do yeah i mean
this has always been true throughout all
of history and i think this may
especially be true now
because men are extremely confused by
feminism and they're told that
traditionally masculine virtues and
behaviors are toxic and poisonous and
they shouldn't engage in them so they're
very confused the idea that a man
would pursue a woman is now considered
shocking and politically incorrect
it was true throughout throughout all of
human history but now it's it's
considered
really unfashionable so yes i think it's
perfectly right
for women to express their interest in a
man
you know this doesn't mean you you're
going to behave exactly like a man would
uh but it does mean you can you know
flirt a little bit with the guy
express some sort of interest i think
it's great it was a great relief to me
in my younger single days
when when a woman would express some
interest so i know i'm not going in
totally blind
and i i suspect it would be even more of
a relief to men these days who
were even more confused by the madness
of feminism and modernity
from brandon dear michael mostly
peaceful podcaster my question is in
regard to christianity
i became a christian roughly three years
ago and have worked hard to strengthen
my faith
i'm by nature a very skeptical person
which has presented many obstacles for
me along the way with being confident in
my beliefs
the i'm going to pause it right there
forget who said this
it was either ronald knox or fulton
sheen or john henry newman i don't i
don't remember i was confused all of
their quotes
the line is this ten thousand questions
do not make one doubt yes you can have
problems you can have questions you
cannot quite get it that's
that is part of faith i mean you by
definition you can't comprehend god if
you could he wouldn't be god
so that's fine and i think grappling
with these things intellectually will
will ultimately strengthen your faith if
you continue to grapple with them okay
you go on the biggest hurdle that i
can't seem to quite get around
is the idea that there are people who
practice other religions islam to be
specific
that feel just as confident in their
religion as we do in ours
understanding that both of these cannot
be true how do you gain confidence in
the gospels and in your faith more
specifically knowing that others out
there feel just as convicted
okay i have a few things to say about
this
one i assume you're a conservative
not everyone who listens to this show is
conservative we have a strong healthy
number of
of liberals moderates and even some
leftists who listen
but statistically speaking you're likely
to be more on the conservative side of
the aisle
but half the country doesn't agree with
you and they're just as strong in their
convictions as you are in yours
so does that mean that you can't
possibly be right because people
disagree with you about politics
no obviously not so if you believe that
politics
has some kind of objective standard
people can be right or wrong
some things are true some things are
false why why do you not believe that
about religion
i suppose you you might not believe that
about religion means we're told
today that religion is just a sort of
subjective feeling or value or
preference
and it's just a kind of quirk of history
and and so back in the day people
believe this now people believe this
soon someday they'll believe this next
thing it's just kind of a
weird facet of human nature but that's
not true religion is the fundament it's
the basis
of all knowledge and all all human
society so
some things just like in politics
because all politics ultimately
is theological some things are going to
be true something's going to be false
some things are going to be good
something's going to be bad now in the
case of islam
i want to be careful here because i have
a great deal of respect for practicing
muslims and i
find that i can speak to practicing
muslims
in a in a much deeper way than i can
speak to your average decadent secular
lib atheist
because because the practicing muslims
believe in god they
at least accept that basis of reality
whereas the kind of decadent apathetic
modern libs they just say like i don't
know i just want to buy stuff and you
know
sleep around and just i don't know
pleasure myself
so i have a great deal of respect for
muslims however
i have religious disagreements with
muslims i have a basic one would be
well i suppose just as in the history of
religion islam
develops as an historical circumstance
because muhammad has an encounter with a
heretical christian monk
the heretical christian monk is known as
bahira in the arabic tradition and
sergius in the western tradition
and nobody denies that this guy existed
and then sometime later
muhammad develops islam muslims believe
as a revealed religion christians
believe as a christian heresy
and you you can see the many ways in
which it
has similarities to other christian
heresies notably denying the divinity of
christ
though admiring him in some ways uh in
its uh
belief in the total transcendence of god
of allah
that god is pure will christianity
believes that god is logos god is the
divine logic of the universe
in islam they believe that allah is is
pure will and pope benedict xvi in the
wonderful regensburg address
quotes ibn hazm as describing this
distinction
so that would be one difference that i
think is just not tenable i think that's
why
why islam kind of falls apart when you
really start to prod it whereas
christianity holds up
the the other aspects here i think is if
you
engage with the person of christ i think
you you find that he is who he says he
is and uh
therefore he cannot be the presentation
of him in islam or any of the other
religions or any
of the other heretical christian sects
or anything else so
what you need to do is recognize that
just as you would in a scientific
pursuit you know we were talking about
the evidence that men are not women
earlier
just as you would in a political pursuit
the idea that that some things are good
and
bad and more efficient and less
efficient in the political sphere
so too you can apply your faculties of
reason according to objective reality to
the religious
sphere and i think christianity wins out
i say this as a former
atheists of 10 years who has studied in
some depth
uh most of the world religions read the
quran
you know i'm i'm not by no means an
expert on these things but i have at
least thought about them
and i was convinced and you should be
too from halle hello mr knowles just got
a signed copy of your book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
can't wait to start reading it thank you
halle that's great my question for you
is
in regards to the claim that racism is
built into the foundation of the
constitution and america as a country
i certainly don't believe that but i
wanted to ask how i would refute this
statement when someone uses the example
of the three-fifths compromise
which i actually learned in grade school
sad how much education has gone downhill
love to hear how you would argue against
this well in the case of the
three-fifths compromise
this was a compromise when the
constitution was being
formed and the issue was
not as modern liberals present it the
modern left will say
that the proof of america's white
supremacists they believed that blacks
were only two
or three fifths rather of a person and
you say
what do you think that means you think
do you think the compromise was the
south wanted to believe that blacks were
not people at all and then the good
free north wanted to believe that blacks
were real people was that the distinct
because it was actually the opposite
right it was the south that wanted to
count for purposes of political
representation in the house of
representatives
they wanted to count black slaves as
full people because then that would grow
their population numbers the north and
the people who opposed slavery in
particular
wanted to count black slaves not as
people at all precisely because they
believed in their humanity and they
didn't want the south
to have disproportionate representation
in the federal government
so they came to this compromise at the
time of the ratification
there were deep debates over slavery
first of all
racism is a word that doesn't mean
anything anymore and the only
if it means not having sort of antipathy
for people of other races or if it even
means
not making any judgments based on on
race of other people
then surely we are the only society in
the history of the world that has not
been racist every other society
everywhere else in the world
is so that's perfectly wonderful thing
about us but then why would you hold
us in particular responsible for racism
the thing that we uniquely don't engage
in
that would be very very crazy
furthermore at the time of the
constitution there were people arguing
strenuously against
slavery even people who own slaves
because this is a fallen world and we
deal
with sin and difficult circumstances and
then we got rid of slavery rather
quickly actually
within some decades of the ratification
what about us what are people going to
say about us we kill a million babies a
year
and it's totally legal and it's fine
we're not even fighting that hard
against it
is america a rotten infanticidal place
yeah in some ways but we're doing our
best and so the question is do you love
your country do you not love your
country do you want to defend your
country
and improve your country in some ways or
not i certainly would like to but that
the framing is really what matters here
final question from andrew hey michael
do you think morality is subjective or
objective i see an overwhelming amount
of people with the mindset that it's
subjective
and i personally think that's dangerous
opinion to have because if morality is
subjective then one could morally
justify anything
you're right it has to be objective or
there's just no
such thing as morality i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
i'll see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin